we'll block it we'll just have to see
how this works out but everybody be
careful
jeff thank you now to the explosion of
wildfires
in the west dozens of people are dead in
three states
at least 24 people are missing in
california more than
three million acres have been burned and
about
16 and a half thousand firefighters are
trying to quell the flames
this eerie footage is from the city of
talent in oregon
where burned out streets look like
they've been paved with pink flame
retardant
jonathan vigliotti is tracking this
historic disaster
crews are using cadaver dogs to search
through charred rubble in southeastern
oregon
looking for any sign of the missing oh
my god
fast moving flames ripped through nearly
half a dozen towns last week giving
residents
little time to escape even heavy duty
fire retardant was not enough to save
these homes some like ashley britton are
seeing the destruction
for the first time it's the worst thing
i've ever seen in my life
is i had seen videos but it's
a thousand times worse than i could have
ever imagined
firefighters across the west have been
battling shifting winds
as they try to gain control of more than
100
fires the hazardous smoke is so severe
the national weather service says it has
created a haze across the country
all the way to washington d.c and alaska
airlines announced
it was temporarily suspending flights to
and from
portland oregon and spokane washington
due to the smoke
dave monroe lives in hard hit talent
oregon
there's something going on that's for
sure man because it's
one thing after another every summer we
were burning up
in california wildfires have now burned
an area
larger than the size of connecticut the
state's governor
gavin newsom i've been on so many fires
over the last seven eight years
throughout the state we've never been
more stretched in our resources
than over the last month
and the fire where we are is the
deadliest so far in california
this year 40 of it has been contained in
oregon mobile morgues have been brought
in
that's where more than two dozen people
are still missing this morning